when I was at when I was a kid growing
up I was always nervous about girls and
how girls would perceive me or see me
for my condition and I'm gonna be
totally open and honest for me I was
like if I could just lose my virginity
once that's all I thought or cared about
at the time I mean they did I'm John the
accountant that's me
I know a bit about you it's all not too
good can I ask you specifically what
your disability is so I was born two
months premature diagnosed with [ __ ]
diplegia which is a form of cerebral
palsy it affects my legs and my muscle
growth and strength standing and walking
is difficult or it used to be a lot more
difficult than it is today
but yes pretty much anyone is I'm a
right leg above knee amputee but I've
also got less like totally paralysis
bill lower than me I acquired this back
in 1989 when I was 24 I had a motorbike
accident and unfortunately I was left
for dead and was it the way you landed
when I came round I was in a bad state
yeah I knew that had at least broken my
leg and then another motor just drove
drove over me so I was knocked off and
then driven over and that's that's when
they reckon I sustained
you know the sort of fait accompli
almost fatal injuries I have now gone I
mean for me with my condition it was
sort of all I know but first someone
like yourself who was able-bodied how
was that transition you don't come to
terms with being thrust into being all
of a sudden a disabled person it was
horrible
I had that time to be disabled to live a
normal life and then not not be able to
do things it's how do you cope when was
the first time you felt excluded because
you had because your disability was not
accounted for for me it's when I first
came to our hospital back in 1989 a
disabled person was still
institutionalized so I got into my home
couldn't get out again that's when I
felt as though society to let me down
you just feel as though is this gonna be
my life now I'm gonna always have these
issues to get over suffered with
clinical depression I'm tried to commit
suicide so after my accident when did
you actually feel as though you know you
felt excluded probably my school days
people would look at you like you're
some sort of alien they didn't
understand why you sort of walked the
way you did or
your legs book pen and I remember sort
of crying to myself one night thinking
you know why am I sort of the chosen one
to have had this condition and how do I
move forward from it
there's always trials and tribulations
that have sort of put me on the back
foot but it just sort of built me into
Who I am today in terms of not taking no
for an answer
and push him forward and staying true to
myself everyone struggles mentally yeah
I think life is 90% mental
10% physical absolutely and if someone
says that they don't struggle mentally
they're lying how does your disability
affect your love life and here's a great
question great question how did it
affect my love life I don't think it
does to be honest no obviously there's
certain limitations to to what you can
and can't do a good relationship will
work around those issues and you just
make you more fun for me when I was it
when I was a kid growing up I was always
nervous about girls and how girls would
perceive me or see me for my condition
and I'm gonna be totally open and honest
for me I was like if I could just lose
my virginity once that's all I sort of
cared about at the time so I have a lot
of able-bodied parents come to me the
mum asked me you know what would he be
like sort of being with a girl or having
sex with a girl or whatever and I just I
just pointed to my girlfriend I love
that I've got a girlfriend you know we
have we're happy together any issues
that you feel that you would have in a
relationship because your disability I
think is irrelevant
what's something people always ask you
do you have to by choosing you have to
by shooting that's what I always get us
yeah how has accessibility changed in
your life time I'd been quite fortunate
because I can still walk and move even
though I couldn't initially at times I
would always make sure I could get where
I needed to go to without potentially
asking people or needing certain aids or
access but it hasn't necessarily
affected me personally which I'm sure is
probably different to you when I was
first injured if I could if I found a
public house or a restaurant that would
be my public house or a restaurant that
I would go to all the time because I
knew that I could access it you know I
can remember going to Civic buildings
and there was no ramp I actually got out
on my wheelchair I'm bummed up the
stairs you know and dragged my
wheelchair behind me I've noticed over
though over the course of time that
thing is a game better I wouldn't say
that the perfect TT do you wake up in
the morning and wish you weren't
disabled at times yeah but those are
Suns where you feel like you're glad you
are have you learnt more about yourself
being disabled then you did being able
bodied I don't like life as a disabled
person I wish I was able bodied I feel
as though and they do because I'm a
wheelchair user I feel as though
sometimes people look down on you do you
ever feel that your disability is an
inconvenience to others I perceive my
disability is an inconvenience to others
I try and make it there isn't and
sometimes I'm too stubborn for my thumb
for my own good and never ask for help
when clearly help is needed I don't see
it as an inconvenience in a slightest if
someone did see it as an inconvenience
it wouldn't make any difference to my
mentality towards it for me it's all
about making things as easy and as most
convenient for myself I always have a
motto
it doesn't isn't it's not like a special
one it's just how I use it and it's you
know if there was a fence and I need to
get over the fences I don't care how I
look whether I call over it whether
people laugh whilst I try and get
everywhere I go through it as long as I
get over it I don't really cares who
were you role models when you were
growing up Manning
I would say my main role models
definitely got to be my parents tried to
keep me as as independent as possible
where I had to learn to do everything
next role model has got to be Alex and
RD
Alexson Adi was an able-bodied racing
driver crashed in 2001 lost both legs
you know he was very inspirational to me
my role model really is came about when
I got back into the workplace after my
accident this gentleman came along to
interview me measure me up for
wheelchair and this gentleman was a
high-level Seif c67 tetraplegic he drove
a manual car so he lived life to the
fullest and his disability didn't get in
his way
and I supposed that person a gay
gentleman cost you had done he became my
role model and he was just somebody that
I've always looked up to because he just
got on with life when did you first come
across his sport so I'm a British
Touring Car driver
I decided I wanted to race cars my dad
gave me the opportunity I had a modified
car to modify my word to help my
condition the first race was pretty
surreal but it was a good one a positive
step fact that I was racing and
competing with our body people when
beating of body people and realising a
lot of people I was starting to inspire
I've been involved in archery from
nineteen I've been told
current day and it's been my life it was
never on my radar to go to power and
Paralympic Games so now it's all about
me getting to become the best account
for 2020 Tokyo is my drive it's going to
be my final games I want to go and I
want to sign off from the sport then for
me it's like I hadn't no you know choice
it was either have a life and move
forward go be a condition and actually
try and create something almost see
that's resonated massively with you you
found sport it's given you a purpose
which is exactly the same as me and
you've you've gone to achieve you know
some fantastic feats with being a
disabled person I think it's incredible
what you've done from being able bodied
to having this massive accident have to
really focus on changing your lifestyle
how people perceive you all that sort of
stuff
it's been great meeting you know thanks
so much no way
[Music]